ben affleck and jennifer lopez's
rekindled love continues to thrive i'm
ready i'm excited about it following the
couple's head-turning red carpet
appearance in italy and a pda-packed
night at the met ben has made it clear
that he thinks his bae is also the goat
we're trying to get some can you see if
we can get in the papers because i'm
trying to get could i could i say in a
new interview this week ben praises
jennifer's impact on the entertainment
industry quote all i can tell you is
that i have seen first hand the
difference representation makes because
i have seen over and over and over and
over women of color approach jennifer
and tell her what her example as a
strong woman and a woman succeeding and
demanding her fair share in the business
world means to them
give it away but it has a very good
ending
ben even goes on to say that jennifer's
influential career is more than he could
ever hope to achieve i am in awe of what
jennifer's effect on the world is at
most as an artist i can make movies that
move people jennifer has inspired a
massive group of people to feel that
they have a seat at the table in this
country that is the effect few people
throughout history have had one i will
never know and one i can only stand by
and admire with respect
these new comments bring to mind what
the actor said about j-lo earlier this
year you know there's always a story of
the month me dating jennifer lopez
happened to be that tablet story at the
time
when
that business grew exponentially back in
january ben shared some harsh words for
critics of their initial romance
people were so mean about her
sexist racist
you know ugly vicious [ __ ] was written
about her in ways that
ben also highlighted the brighter side
of the story in the years since
now it's like she's lionized and
respected for the work she did where she
came from what she accomplished as well
she [ __ ] sure did
did these comments kick off benefit 2.0
all we know for sure is that eight
months later ben and jennifer were
making their red carpet come back at the
venice film festival
[Applause]
the couple was seen laughing having
intimate convos doing all the
hand-holding and sharing a kiss it was
ben and jennifer's first movie premiere
together since 2003's geely
i think we had chemistry as actors from
the first moment we started working this
movie will always be important at a
landmark event in my life the red carpet
moment was quickly followed by yet
another night out for the lovebirds
after j.lo's solo arrival at the met
gala last week the couple reunited
inside and even shared a masked kiss
and all this affection lines up with
some new details et learned about the
relationship it just turned out to be
something really magical a source told
et last week it is like they never broke
up but everything is way better this
time they are all over each other and
their friends joke around about it with
them
[Music]
you